SPEAKER: In this video, we'll go
over setting up a grace period
and how to help a user fix
their payment method to recover
from a grace period.
A grace period for
your subscription
allows your users
to retain access
to your content or services
after a payment has
been missed.
To set up grace period, sign
into the Google Play console,
and select your app.
On the left menu, click Store
Presence, In-app Products.
Then select the Subscriptions
tab, and select a subscription.
You can choose the length
of the grace period
for that subscription--
0, 3, or 7 days.
We recommend also enabling
account hold, which is
covered in a subsequent video.
With real-time
developer notifications,
you'll receive a notification
from Google Cloud Pub/Sub
that a subscription
status has changed.
In this example, it's
entered a grace period.
Call the Google
Play Developer API
from your server to
verify this change,
and then record this
new subscription
information on your back end.
Next, you'll want to provide
a message in your app
that alerts your user
to their account status.
You should also provide them
a deep link to the Google Play
Subscription Center so the user
can fix their payment method.
For more information on
setting up deep links,
visit the link onscreen.
The user should retain
access to your services
throughout the grace period.
For more information,
visit the link onscreen,
or check out our other videos.